It's very necessary for people at some
point in their life to dedicate
themselves to a single game of some
sort,
which is kind of what you're doing in
university,
you know you have to become one thing at
some point in your life and the
sacrifice of course is that you give up
all the other things that you could
become,
but the.
You don't really have a choice because
if you don't decide voluntarily to
become one thing,
you know,
to become a,
a disciplined adherent of some specific
practice or profession or viewpoint,
then you risk just aging chaotically and
you don't get away with not aging,
so you might as well age into something
that's.
That's actually something rather than
just remaining or then just becoming an
old child,
which is really not a not a good thing.
It's not a good thing to see.
Especially by the time people hit about
40.
It's not.
It's not pretty for them or anyone else.
And even at 30 it's getting pretty old
at that point.
40.
It's like it's almost a repairable at 40
and the reason for that is you run,
you start running out of opportunities
when you're young and stupid.
People don't care because they think,
well,
you know,
whatever.
You've got decades of of,
of possibility still ready to unfold in
you,
but if you're in the same unspecified
position at 40,
people are much less forgiving.
Especially because if they're going to
hire someone who doesn't know what's
going on or or employ them or or sorry
or engage them in some sort of
productive activity,
they might as well take a chance on
someone young and full of potential
rather than someone who's really lived
more than half of their life already.
Because of course you have,
by the time you're 40.